we are still here at the scene of this
terrible disaster caused by a massive
tornado which swept through sector zero
one and two
amidst the wreckage of the expressway
search and rescue operations are already
in progress
[Music]
wow just look at it all it's so green
even after everything we've done to it
it's still going strong it may look that
way but in reality it's barely hanging
on
I was wondering what's Cloud been doing
these past five years where's he been
and you're asking me this
this is gonna sound crazy but
but far as I know
Cloud was never in miebelheim five years
ago
a live stream
it is the very essence of our star the
blood coursing through its planetary
veins
according to Hojo they're connected to
sephiroth
Shadows of the man I believe he called
them
sephiroth was in midgar we fought him
whatever happened he's alive but why
come back now
after five years doing who knows what
well now I think we woke it up
angered it more like
[__]
Feast your eyes on the Turks latest and
greatest Elena she may be new
they say she's a monster that she can
pure inside you into the very depths of
your soul
that she can become those you hate those
you fear
those you love
green yeah
murdered my dad
you burned my Village
do you know that I killed her
so who is she
[Music]
I have had enough of you then go before
I put you down
[Music]
today you have proven worthy of joining
us come there are other Champions I must
gather
what do you want sento it's my family
blade cento's mine and I won't give it
up without a fight
oh
[Music]
enough
okay let's go back to one here
who are you again Lord Liu Kang
protector of Earth rail
god of fire
foreign
[Music]
but you're inexperienced whatever
experience I lack I make up for in heart
all right
if your disease becomes known you will
be banished I only want what's best for
you or do you secretly covet my throne
thank you
get over here
[Music]
difference
[Applause]
sounds like somebody's home
foreign
all right
text on the heart is clearer now
I knew it would be here like I saw it in
a dream
I'm glad you're on this case with me
Anderson
killer left a message
it's for us
we were all trapped in a horror story
The Horror Story wanted us dead
there's something I'm forgetting
something important
something's not right
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
help help
ing down
I am the advanced artificial
intelligence Leviathan
Island
foreign
[Music]
our kingdom is cursed
the prince has been kidnapped and taken
to a forbidden land
all hope rests with us the Immortals to
rescue him and save the empire
we weren't prepared for what was coming
next up so I can't say no
then again they weren't prepared for me
came with a purpose now I'm about to
turn it down
don't take a chance
these times of Darkness hope is the only
thing that keeps us fighting
I will fulfill my destiny and save the
kingdom
huh where are the guards
hey you what's going on
[Music]
thank you
I wish this universe had a few more
things to do don't you get bored running
across the map every day
please back from Duty mission one
accomplished where's our next stop I
can't wait
a day ahead of us
[Music]
the tournament's starting great let me
get warmed up
laughs
strike first
need a hand my pleasure
let's see some sports fries
huh never mind I miscalculated
can you let me have some fun this time
[Music]
ecstasy
Japanese puppet
I need your help
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
no
secret Pokemon
listen pal nice landing but uh let's not
make it a habit
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
we're facing a tetanite splinter Fleet
they engaged us on two planets avarax
and kadaku
I'll be straight with you Titus I have
my reservations about your reinstatement
there could be questions will that be a
problem
no Captain
inbound
official rate this abomination
come for them be slaughtered
[Music]
to see if we can slay more dinos
from all
remorse
and the gortash swear us thou by
baldran's blade to defend the citizens
of Boulder's Gate from enemies within
and without
[Music]
you are soon to witness the people of
Baldur's Gate granting me complete power
over there
a new age
gods have mercy on those who would stand
in our way a Mad Dog understands the
yank of the leash on the hand of its
Master but it cannot be an equal you can
be my equal there's an old wisdom a
brittle Alliance can never be mended it
can only break I want to lead this city
to Glory not Scorch at Earth
friends allies to my side
let us Usher in a new dawn this city is
mine
I'm not ready to call you enemy what do
you say
shall we be allies
you said it was under control
gortash
[Music]
relaxation
Naruto
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
sermon okay
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
drugs literally pushed us to the edge
everyone that can fight already is
[Music]
and we're still losing
welcome aboard immortal
what's our bearings sir North by
Northeast five knots
we'll catch him so
happening
get to the control room and protect
Selco and Dara and I will hold off the
roshania down here got it
gotta get to the control
s
[Music]
what's up
foreign
I want to
fight this war as one of you
you're what's called a try on
the pentacide has gifted you with the
ability
to manifest all three colors of magic
[Music]
we're only going to win this one
together
did you look
foreign
[Music]
thank you